is national fried chicken day and the
grief is popping at brooklyn bowl las
vegas chef derma driscoll is here to
tell us how we can celebrate with you
well today i'm ready you ready i am
ready awesome i know that this is not
the chicken i eat no this is the raw
chicken this is the good stuff
uh today is national fried chicken day
so we have dollar wings okay all day
long all night long but what but why
is it worth it because i've heard you've
perfected
this we have a phenomenal product
we bring in a whole chicken okay butcher
it in house keep it really cold
and then we have blue ribbons famous
matzo meal breading
egg whites okay so we've always wondered
what made it blue ribbon what was that
it's the it's the blend of the matzo
it's the spices it's the love that goes
into the habanero
and
we fry it it sizzles and gets real good
we season it with our blend and
it's probably the best fried chicken in
las vegas
i'm throwing that out there right now
okay i will take on the challenge that's
a fighting phrase right there somebody
out there is like
not against my chicken we'll take it
any day of the week i'm gonna go ahead
and which one should i have any one you
want let's see i'm gonna go right here
is this a wing yeah yep okay so when i
bite into this what are the seasonings
i'm tasting you're gonna get a little
bit of cayenne
you're gonna get a little bit of um
hungarian paprika
and you're gonna get a little bit of
magic
the rest of the seasonings are just
magically
mixed together
oh my gosh that is kendall what are you
doing
i told you
it's fried chicken okay oh my goodness
okay this is amazing
amazing what do you think you've been
doing this a long time people out there
who
who might want to try frying some
chicken one day what what makes the what
makes the chicken it's really starting
with good chicken okay that's important
it's really kind of chicken you buy or
raise and then it's good to keep it
really cold before you fry it
get a good seasoning blend you could use
egg whites or you could egg egg blend
mixture
and have a good temperature on your
fryer
whoa seasoning
yeah this is good okay
and last but certainly not least the
best side dishes to go with this chicken
when we're coming to brick and bowl what
else is on the menu collard greens okay
speaking of my language
mashed potatoes with gravy what more do
you need entertainment
we got shows we got two
we do you got everything at brooklyn
bowl thank you so much chef this is
kendall what do you think very very good
you don't need any sides you don't